why not it's great
we were i one day in Shoreditch or
hungover because like what do you want
for lunch so many choices but all we
want to Loserville the cereal and that's
where the idea came from so we thought
let's do it
we get kids coming into the day doctor
but then their parents are coming
because they don't establish your side
of things they don't feeling like your
kids again
it's also the experience that you get
when you're in here you're seeing things
from your childhood you're see them
that's pretty much a Museum of cereal
here so it's not just it's not just a
little Buddhist cereal it's the whole
experience
we know what gentrification is
gentrification is people that are buying
off with tons of houses and selling off
with dolphins and then for some people
like that's not what we're doing
we're selling coconuts for sex Chris